shame on you I am very happy to be here
today with my good friend Antonio
Guterres I know him for so many decades
we have been appointed that rare seventh
five ministers of our respective
countries and since then we are working
in a good atmosphere and I can't
remember an example where we would have
disagreed in a profound way Antonio
Guterres now is the secretary-general of
the United Nations we have come here to
express our admiration for him because
he is doing an excellent job we are here
to say that the multilateral approach is
not that it has to be maintained it's
the only chance we have to shape the
future of the globe in a way which is
acceptable for all the stakeholders we
don't like unilateral approach some of
our members of the United Nations
promoting this is the wrong way we do
think that multi RISM has has to have a
chance and it's difficult but that's a
venue for the future so we are saying
that we are supporting the UN system I
don't like that expression United
Nations because United Nations are
paving the way to a better future for
Humanity United Nations the constant
earth whatever it is multilateralism and
european union will always be the
partner of the United Nations and if
Antonia - I want to very warmly welcome
John Kluge on care my dear friend
jean-claude juncker and the delegation
of the European Union the European Union
is an exemplary partner of the United
Nations we share the same concern in
favour of multilateralism and in favor
of the rules-based international order
and we are working together in many
scenarios around the world those for
peace and security for sustainable
development for the promotion
protection of human rights we have the
same concern about climate change and
the fact that climate change is running
faster than what we are and the need to
have climate action as a absolutely
central global priority and on the other
hand we are extremely grateful for the
direct support the European Union has
been providing both to the reform of the
UN to many of our operations around the
world in humanitarian and development
areas but also from the peace and
security perspective support to the CL
support to several other African
operations strong commitment to a
political solution in Syria in Yemen in
Libya in other dimensions very
constructive attitude relation to the
global compact on refugees and so it is
for me an enormous pleasure to once
again be able to verify that our
partnership is on very solid ground it
will be increasing and that we have a
common view over the biggest challenges
that the planet is facing thank you very
much thank you did I say that we are
supporting the reform initiatives at the
secretary-general if I didn't do it now